[Music]
and everyone hear me okay perfect cool
so my name is Johnny I'm a staff
engineer in Washington DC working at a
company called morning consult and today
I want to talk to you about a very bike
Shetty worthy topic which is finding
your abstractions sweet spot so moving
right along this begs the question what
exactly is an abstraction before we get
into that though I want to talk just a
little bit about simplicity and
complexity so we've all heard the mantra
keep it simple stupid and truth be told
other than being a bit rude I think it's
a bit misguided as well the fact of the
matter is simple doesn't really scale
it's really easy to get that hello world
up and going and you know the first
couple months of the thing you're trying
to build it's really great but if you
have any amount of success things get
really big really complex really quickly
so how do you embrace this idea of
simplicity while accounting for
inevitable complexity right so we don't
want kiss what I tend to think about is
elegance right I think this is what we
really mean when we say to keep things
simple right elegance I define as
complexity expressed simply and the
go-to metaphor I tend to use is if you
think about all of our reality all of
space and all that it exists right there
are trillions and trillions of
of protons and photons and whatnot in
the universe and they all come together
to form everything you see around you
you know stars and planets and meteors
and even you and I you know living
organisms that's a hugely complex system
but it's really interesting that all of
reality as we understand it today can
also be expressed in the language of
mathematics that's an incredibly elegant
thing we don't know why there's a big
argument and you know physics about you
know whether math is real whether it's
not you know do you discover math or do
you invent it that's a completely
different talk out of the realm of my
particular expertise but I think it's
really elegant nonetheless don't keep it
simple and keep it elegant so with that
said what is an abstraction in this
context I like to think about an
abstraction as the degree to which
complexity is encapsulated and going a
little bit deeper here I like to think
about things in terms of strong and weak
abstractions when you think about a
strong abstraction it encapsulates a lot
of complexity and this is not
necessarily a good thing right there are
many times when you don't necessarily
want to hide a ton of complexity when
you want to maximize the amount of
flexibility you give people who consume
your api's and we'll talk a little bit
about that later conversely a weak
abstraction encapsulated very little
complexity and you know pejorative to
the term weak itself this is not
necessarily a bad thing sometimes you
actually need people to be able to get
down to the the nuts and bolts of what
you're providing them because that's
what they need in order to be able to
build something on top of your platform
games seem to be really popular this
year at Jas comp and I swear I put this
up before I saw all the other games that
were available so this is gonna be
called guess the API so essentially the
way it works I'm gonna show you a small
code snippet and then you're gonna use
context clues to figure out which fame
javascript api invokes this
implementation so we'll go through an
example real quick if i were to show you
this block of code you'd look at it pick
up some context clues you know you see
the word app create application all this
good stuff does anyone have any idea
where this block of code comes from oh
if you have any idea if you wrote this
code or if you're otherwise familiar
with it you are not allowed to
participate and if you cheat may your
life be filled with misery forever
anyone yes express application but
specifically which function it's alright
you alright it's basically when you
invoke express itself at the root right
so that's the only example I have the
others aren't gonna be that easy I pick
stuff without revealing docs but you get
the point right all right ready
here's the next one picking up context
clues there's some event stuff in here
some listener stuff anyone want to take
a stab even omit heard that on it's
pretty good alright yeah so this is
whenever anyone in node and uses an
event emitter and calls a dot on an
event that's the code that gets invoked
most notably in like strings but also
when you're come creating like HTTP
servers and things like that what about
this one this one might be a little bit
easy there's props in a very particular
library all over the place react what
react dot
right we act out create element so
somebody's mad so what's the point here
the point is to illustrate that you know
with some context clues you can kind of
get an idea what's going on but the fact
of the matter is there's like nothing
wrong with this code itself you know
unless you hate semicolons or whatever
but the idea is that I wanted to
illustrate the entropy that's involved
in creating the abstractions that you
use every day someone had to like write
this so you can essentially write this
this doesn't just apply to code either
when you think about abstractions on
what they're useful for they're all over
the place most notably when we think
about infrastructure right this is a big
thing that's been happening you know
within the industry really for I guess
about the last ten years a lot of
innovation has been happening but really
the last few years is when things that
really heat up and I want to talk a bit
about going up the abstraction chain to
kind of figure out to kind of illustrate
exactly why these things are important
and the big milestones that we've seen
so for those of us who are around when
you need it to essentially have access
to a physical server to actually deploy
something whether it's a website or
what-have-you
this is a very imperative workflow to
actually get your stuff deployed right
needed to know a lot of things you
needed to know where the server was you
needed to know security credentials to
get into the server you needed to know
where on the server to put your
deployable artifacts it was a very very
imperative thing and you know and when I
say you need to know where it was
sometimes I was just in your bedroom
right so moving forward a little bit
someone had a great idea to just use
virtual machines the idea is like forget
the hardware but I do need a computer
right and so began this whole revolution
of computer emulation right a whole
level of abstraction that was really a
game-changer in
portability for the first time really
the thing on which your application
relied and wasn't necessarily the host
operating system on which your stack
actually ran and this was huge
so moving up a little bit we talked
about containers a bit right forget the
computer all I really need our computer
resources right this is a while computer
resource emulation right I don't need a
UI I need a start menu that's kind of
dumb what I really need is a file system
CPU and you know memory other stuff and
that's what I need to run my application
and so the abstraction gets a bit
stronger platform-as-a-service
this was really great as well because it
allowed you to not even have to think
about what your application was running
on that was irrelevant most of the time
right there are caveats here as well but
the idea is the only thing you ship is
an application and someone else worries
about everything else that was your
interface to your deployments right
forget the compute resources mostly
here's my app run it which brings us to
the current revolution which is
serverless
right forget the application and the
computer I'm gonna ship business logic I
want you to take care of essentially
everything else and that's kind of where
we are now and you see this continuously
evolving and getting more and more
strong with as an extraction and you see
where the benefits are for getting
things up and running really closely but
you also encounter situations where the
strong abstractions don't really make
sense other people need to use other
things so what can go wrong well short
answer is a lot so breaking changes when
you're not focusing on thinking about
this up front at least to some extent
you really run the risk of having a lot
of braking changes
occur when you're developing your
software right and you end up with non
backward compatibility software which
forces you to essentially abandon users
or have a lot of support over a long
time and to be told to many breaking
changes is gonna prevent you from being
able to sell to large enterprise
customers they're very risk-averse
you know if you think about customers
like you know the government or people
that operate in highly regulated
industries like the finance industry and
whatnot they will not use your software
if it's not stable tech that you could
go the other direction right if you
decide to keep those major versions in
place but you still need to make a lot
of changes you're gonna have to do a lot
of contorting in order to be able to
maintain that backward compatibility
we've all worked in those code bases
where we didn't want to break anything
or we absolutely couldn't break anything
but we had to make fixes and so this add
tool created a lot of tech debt in the
weight and was no clear path to actually
cleaning it up without essentially a
complete refactor or a rewrite user
confusion um so this one is a bit less
obvious but if you get your abstraction
wrong or if it's not ideal there's gonna
be a lot of confusion within the
communities that consume your software I
remember back when the angularjs one dot
X version first landed and it was
absolutely a game changer for front-end
development I still remember the demo on
the home page now or you know they
demonstrated like the two-way
data-binding and it was like amazing and
this was great but then something
happened I guess about 24 months had
gone by companies had started adopting
angularjs is like you know something
that was real and then people actually
started building a really big robust web
applications using angularjs and then
what happens is you get to a place where
you need to make a deployment or you're
getting close to the end but you have
some last-minute requirement changes it
happens all the time
but you've architected your application
in such a way that your directives need
to communicate which other in a very
elegant way but you didn't architect you
didn't account for this right this is
before we had sort of you know before
Redux was really a thing and we had like
really mature sort of like state
management solutions on the front end
and so what would happen is people would
try to get two directives to talk to
each other very quickly and instead of
having to refactor the way the
communication messaging happened they
would adopt what I refer to as the
spray-and-pray architecture and you take
advantage of angular's dependency
injection you inject route scope and you
do a route scope that broadcasts and you
just throw out data out into the ether
and you hope that some directive
somewhere actually receives it some of
you know what I'm talking about you look
guilty you put your heads down you know
I've been there trust me and it
certainly wasn't angular's fault this is
you know this is the abstraction that we
were given in order to build our
applications and it just so happens that
when trying to scale out these
applications these are the challenges we
ran into in fact a lot of these issues
were some of the the early inspirations
for you know architect before libraries
like you know react and view etc and so
these are the type of things that can
happen right and this is not bashing
angular 1.x I'm a big fan I don't think
it deserved half the flak it receive so
the reason you're all here where's my
sweet spot how can I figure out where I
need to be placing my abstractions such
that it benefits both myself and my
users so opinions opinions opinions
warning so the big thing I think that
everyone should really think about is
flexibility versus ease of use right
this is the big one this is gonna be
your ultimate trade-off the idea is the
more flexible you are
you're gonna tend to sacrifice some ease
of use right
this is gonna be your weaker
abstractions with flexibility this is
gonna be your low-level stuff this is
gonna be your you know your your WebGL s
of the world which are really great but
someone like me who is like not a 3d
program or like I need like I need
something higher level I need the three
JSS of the world or even higher than
that truth be told
versus ease of use right if you are a 3d
programmer and you really know what
you're doing a lot of the helpers out
there are just gonna get in your way
more than anything else and so maybe
that's not what you need and so what you
have to do is figure out where your
users are and make sure that you're
meeting them where they are similar to
that you have to consider your audience
right who are you building for is this
internal or external right if it's
internal you can get away with a lot of
stuff if it's external when people are
going to be using this either as a
project a product or maybe just an
open-source tool you need to make sure
that you have that correct understanding
what are people using your stuff to
build with you know you can't control
that but it may come into play right
this is when you really get intimate
with the users and figure out what
they're doing platforms this is a good
one as well some platforms and languages
lend themselves better to certain levels
of abstraction practitioners of a
language might regularly work on a
certain level write JavaScript
developers generally want objects and
strings that sort of thing maybe some
arrays golang developers they want
buffers interfaces and errors apparently
if you ever looked at some go code rust
developers want jobs just kidding
that's a troll I love rust it's a great
language lifespan this is a big one as
well right this is very similar to you
know the breaking changes if you very
upfront with your audience and you uses
about the type of timeline they can
expect for support this is gonna inform
the level at which you actually you know
write your software that's gonna be
really important so coming to wrap
things up a little bit you want to make
sure you focus on elegance and not just
simplicity simplicity won't scale no
one's gonna buy anything that's simple
right because anyone can reproduce your
work if you're gonna be successful
you're gonna inevitably head towards
complexity the best thing you can do is
account for it in a way that allows for
you to build a competitive product but
also ensures that you users are happy
think in terms of weak or strong
abstractions and when is the right time
to use either one sometimes you need to
support the whole spectrum right that's
something that's really important that's
gonna take a lot of resources is gonna
take a lot of time maybe you start at
one minute of spectrum and you end up on
the other this is a decision that you
have to make so remember the trade-offs
of flexibility and ease of use very
similar to the previous point there are
real trade-offs here and you need to
make them as close to the upfront as you
can but not necessarily completely think
about the consequences of getting it
wrong
frequent breaking changes tech dead user
confusion there's nothing you can do to
avoid all of these things unfortunately
part of the planning upfront is to make
sure that you know that you're gonna
accumulate that tech debt so just have a
plan to kind of pay it pay it down right
or if you're gonna have frequent
breaking changes maybe you just want to
launch in a beta for awhile and make
sure people understand that upfront if
you know that you know this is gonna be
crazy and maybe people are gonna be a
bit confused then focus more on you know
developer reach out making sure people
know exactly how to use your software
and always think about your audience
right they're the most important folks
you can have the bed
written software the best product in the
world but if no one's gonna buy it and
if no one wants to use it then you're
essentially you know dead in the water
and with that thanks
[Music]